let's bring in our security expert
advice Marshall Sean Bell
um now obviously there's little in the
way of fact at the moment surrounding uh
this incident but what we do know is
that it's absolutely extraordinary that
there's been this alleged attack on the
Kremlin talk us through the footage
that's swirling around social media yeah
it is amazing footage I mean this is the
head of power for Russia if this was the
house of parliament it will be
absolutely front page news this is is
really critical now Russia claims this
is a Ukrainian drone strike but it also
Russia claims that there were two drones
and that their military and special
forces and electronic warfare took them
out I have to say it doesn't look like
they took them out based on this footage
we're seeing now but if we take a closer
look at the footage we can analyze this
in a slightly slower speed first of all
the Drone doesn't appear to be a very
fast drone obviously we've slowed it
down here but the initial footage is
very slow uh and also we can see it's
not a particularly large drone we can
see see two people on the roof of the
building there who are as a for a
relative size we can now compare them
with the size of the Drone and whilst
that it's very difficult to tell
accurately but it doesn't look like a
big aircraft sized drone but it's also
not a Micro Drone if we wind the footage
forward a little bit further we see that
the Drone doesn't actually hit its
Target that actually misses the top of
the building and explodes just after it
goes past the top of the building so it
may have some sort of proximity charge
to it or it may have been the operator
having realized he was going to miss
actually detonates it just above if we
just want the footage forward a few more
frames just there you can now see that
part of the burning wreckage Falls onto
the roof and that's important because
later on there's another bit of footage
that seems to imply there's been a hole
into the roof whereas in reality it
hasn't it's just burning uh wreckage and
finally if we move forward just a little
bit further you can see the plumer smoke
now for the um for our viewers that's
not a lot of smoke for an explosion
that's more a hand grenade size
explosion not a bomb size Expo which
gives an idea of the sort of relative
charge that's involved in this attack so
look it looks like
a nine attack nevertheless
managed to penetrate
kremlin's boundaries what one would
think that the Kremlin would have better
defenses than that Sean one of the
things that I I failed to understand at
the moment is it's going to be a
fortress the Kremlin will be a fortress
with lots of layers of air defense
whether it's big missile systems to
combat uh big threats all the way down
through automatic gunfire to electronic
warfare there will be a whole panoply of
defenses and somehow at least one of
these drones has got through now as we
said militarily it's not particularly
significant hasn't done any damage
probably just needs a lick of paint and
it'll be all back to normal again but
symbolically this is absolutely huge
it's on not quite the eve but it's the
ninth of May is meant to be Victory Day
which Putin wanted to celebrate and
actually the rest of the Russian
population particularly in the Kremlin
in in Moscow itself will have seen this
and that brings the harsh reality of
warfare actually onto their doorstep and
for Putin who's known to be a little bit
apprehensive about his own safety it
demonstrates quite clearly that Ukraine
can reach out and touch him even when
he's in a stronghold of the Kremlin yeah
I think that's what's especially
extraordinary isn't it is that he is
known for his paranoia and this footage
certainly is is dramatic and and
extraordinary to to anyone watching but
especially to to Russian civilians now
let's talk about who's saying what
Ukraine denies any connection to this
attack Russia is saying that this was a
Ukrainian drone attack an attempt on on
Vladimir Putin's life what what do we
actually know almost certainly if it was
trying to be a impact on his life that
had been a bigger charge that wasn't the
case it looks like it's far more
symbolic it's part of we're watching
fuel sites being targeted Sebastopol
fuel sites being targeted on the curse
bridge this is all fugel's like the
opening overtures of the spring
offensive before they're actually on the
attack to deceive to distract Russian
forces uh on the uh on the start of that
campaign but and reflection I would just
very glad I'm not head of Putin's
security Arrangement the Kremlin today
because that is a grave breach of
security to get through those defenses
and interestingly we do know that
Vladimir Putin she wasn't in the Kremlin
when this happened but certainly
Ukraine's concern now is that this could
be used as a pretext for escalated
attacks on Ukraine